les masques qui devait protéger nos
enfants et le personnel qui veillent sur
eux pourraient s'avérer nuisible pour
leur santé santé canada vient d'émettre
une mise en garde relative aux masques
snn 200 642 une évaluation préliminaire
des risques a révélé un potentiel de
toxicité pulmonaire précoce liée à
l'inhalation de graphène nano forme et
j'en ai pris 9,1 comment sur un court
les ministères québécois de la famille
de l'éducation et de l'enseignement
supérieur recommande donc aux
établissements visés de cesser
immédiatement d'utiliser ces masques lee
bolduc est très inquiet sa fille à
porter près d'une centaine de ces
masques depuis bientôt trois mois
ma fille me disait souvent en sortant de
l'école papa j'ai l'impression que j'ai
des poils dans la bosse dans la bouche
avec ses masques leur faire tout c'est
aller perdu et cancale enlevé lé masque
ça se règle est c'était toujours comme
ça les syndicats aussi sont préoccupés
de la situation qu'est ce qu'on fait
l'audi le sécuritaire les milieux de
garde avait déjà été échaudé par une
situation similaire des masques non
conforme avait été distribué dans le
réseau entre mai et novembre
c'est la deuxième fois qu'on en voit
dans le réseau des masques qui ne
répondent pas aux exigences dans leur
première fois c'était qu'elle ne
répondait pas totalement conformité
cette fois ci on nous parle d'un dodge
d'un danger potentiel pour la
travailleuse par le fait du matériau
avec lesquels ils sont faits de quoi
ébranler la confiance des parents mais
aussi de tout le personnel des écoles et
des garderies concernés à l'aube d'une
troisième vague ici julie aimant radio
canada montréal